I don't know what it is about redheads
but first Emma Stone and now Jessica
Chastain I can't take no more of this
we should never forget how young they
were thirty years ago these three dared
to confront an unimaginable evil the
Death Star's Helen Mirren Jessica
Chastain Sam Worthington or me as so
many people keep telling me Marlin soca
Syrian Hines and Tom Wilkinson I messed
up any of those names my bet also a lot
of people don't seem to realize this but
this film was co-written by Matthew
Vaughn the director of this year's x-men
first class also this film is directed
by John Madden yeah not that one
that'd be funny that doesn't make
interesting movie wouldn't it this film
jumps between two time periods where we
see the younger version of three
characters and then the much more mature
and older version of the same three
characters in the future and we get to
see that the decisions they've made in
the past how it affected them in the
future the time period that passes about
these three people who are on a secret
mission to try to capture and bring to
justice a man who is responsible for the
deaths of many thousands of Jews without
spoiling anything I'll just say that
some serious complications ensue on
their mission which causes them to have
to make a lot of really hard decisions
that affect them later in life Stephan
Gould was the youngest unit commander in
Mossad David Perez that is 29th birthday
while on the mission Rachel singer
was only 25 when you crossed through the
checkpoint into Soviet controlled East
Berlin no one's really talking about
this movie and it's been getting some
good reviews and some good buzz and
makes me feel bad cuz I'm sure no one's
gonna see this movie and I'm sure people
are gonna go see shark Night 3d and
Apollo 18 over in this film if I'm wrong
I'd be really happy but this is a really
good film with a really strong and
riveting story held together by a lot of
great performances Helen Mirren and
Jessica Chastain in particular are
excellent in this film both playing the
same character in two different time
periods I really think the Chastain
should be nominated for an Oscar for her
role in this film I hope that my other
YouTube film critics to this movie as
well so I'm not the only one at your
reviewers time layer this year saying
that she deserves it craft of the film
was very taut very tightly weaved there
was a lot of really good scenes and a
lot of great interaction between
characters you really got to know these
three characters really well because
they're there with each other a lot of
times in this house in this place where
they're staying and you just they talk a
lot with each other and so you learn a
lot about their lives their backstories
and you really go attach these
characters and it becomes really
interesting and you feel for them and
that's how you make a good movie you
gotta have characters that you feel for
you can't just have these cookie cut out
people written in scripts if you care
for the characters you'll care about
what happens there in the movie the
first time in the field
good that's good
welcome to the mission I found the film
very realistic and that was really a
great strength this movie because most
of the actors in this film especially
the older more veteran actors have been
in a lot of movies like this where
they're dealing with really serious
situations and they just pull it off
like Tom Wilkinson for instance take
ghostwriter Michael Clayton or even
Batman Begins he plays characters with
they just seem so real and he is great
in this film as well my only problem
with the film was that it it's not the
kind of movie that just outright starts
off and says okay this is the plot this
is what's happening this is what the
characters are doing you don't even
really understand what they're doing
until some some way through the film you
get little tidbits of information okay
that's why they're there okay that's
what they're doing oh I see it's not
just like your mission if you choose to
accept it is this like you don't find
out like that you have to kind of learn
and in a way that is really cool but at
the same time it was just I got a little
annoying at first I was like what are
they doing tell me what they're doing
now but I think that's kind of their
filmmakers wanted they wanted you to be
able to grasp for the story to try to
figure out what was going on it made me
want to know more and it it just I
really actually liked it so anyway my
only flaw of the film actually benefits
the film we take him back alive
wish of the world what he did yet
Rembrandt I think you're the one that is
afraid David afraid of the monster I
have basically nothing to save a good
things about this film the performances
are excellent the script is good the
direction is very well done and I just I
had a lot of fun this movie III really
think you should see it don't go to this
movie expect me to be like an action
film it's not an action film some people
might call it slow
I call it interesting that's just me
from beginning to end of this movie I
wanted to know what was gonna happen I
wanted to see it now
the dead so I'm gonna give the debt at a
- I really think you should see it I
really do
check it out it's in theaters now came
out on Wednesday give it a shot so if
you like my review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuff mine eyes